you've stolen all my unreleased music
it's horrible there's no secrets with
you and I Ariana Grande telling it like
it is do you do whatever you want the
singer gets real with her followers in a
YouTube makeup tutorial calling them out
for leaking her unreleased music you
guys have heard every bad song and
demo that I've ever made
hilarious
it's impossible to keep things from you
[Music]
you gotta take some swings and misses
yeah Ari's not exactly happy her
unpublished work has recently made its
rounds on the internet no secrets I'm
all out of Secrets you've stolen all my
unreleased music it's horrible you know
where I am you know what I'm doing you
know all of it you know everything
that's going on you know everything
there's no secrets there's no secrets
with you and I fans definitely know what
Ariana's been up to she's currently
shooting the film adaptation of the
Broadway musical Wicked it's a very
exciting thing for us Ariana who's
starring as Glinda has been sharing
sneak peeks from the set including these
snaps with her co-star Cynthia arivo
taking on the role of alphaba pretty
excited that Ariana and I consistently
texting and talking about what we want
and now the world's getting its first
Glimpse at the stars transformations
Glinda wears a couple of things I told
my beautiful makeup artist Nuria I
wanted to sit down and let you play and
we'll find her together I just wanted to
be
a new girl and find Glenda with her I am
so excited for this
um
it's weird because it's exhausting but I
am not tired like I would do it again
right now every single thing I I don't
want to stop I don't want to do the
weekends I don't want to go home I don't
want to leave ever safe to say she's
over the rainbow about it
play
room for the rainbow
and loving the wicked life Cynthia and I
are this is the phrase we keep saying
husks we are shells of people
and I'm saving every single second
humanly possible for both of us are
working really really hard and we're
trying to bring you something that you
might not expect it is not going to be
too far away hopefully from the stage
but I think you'll get more from it now
I think we'll get more of the story of
the two of these wonderful characters
who have lots of life to get yeah
foreign